One year ago tonight,
we started doing this show.
(cheering and applause)
One year ago. Wow!
Man! Can you believe it?
Whew! That's right, man.
It's our one-year anniversary.
You know what, I have to say,
we got a-a very, very thoughtful
gift.
Um, Donald Trump was kind enough
to talk about religion.
Mm-hmm. Very nice.
Which brings us
to tonight's Unblackening.
(dramatic music playing)
(humming)
Now, one of the key,
uh, constituents
that Donald Trump has to win
over are the evangelicals.
Now, they make up 57%
of the caucus-goers in Iowa.
And according to Trump,
he's in good standing.
I have a very great relationship
with God.
And I have a very great
relationship with evangelicals.
If Trump and God have
a great relationship,
it's probably because
they never see each other.
That can work, right?
All right. So he is winning over
some of the evangelical vote,
but, uh, I think
he's (bleep) about God.
I'm wondering what one or two
of your most favorite
-Bible, uh, verses are and why.
-Well, I-I wouldn't want
to get into it, because, to me,
that's very personal.
Are you an Old Testament guy
or a New Testament guy?
Uh, probably... equal.
Probably equal?
Am I the only one seeing
how transparent this is?
You've never read the Bible,
Donald Trump!
I mean, come on. If
Trump ever even touched a Bible,
it probably sizzled.
But Donald Trump's got
to convince the an...
the evangelicals that he's
as full of Jesus as they are,
so yesterday he took
his dual-testament-loving self
to Liberty University.
Now, the first thing he did,
of course, was brag
about the crowd size.
We broke the record.
You know, we had the record
for about three or four years
the last time.
And the first thing I said to
Jerry and Becki when I got here,
"Did we break the record?"
They said, "Yes, you did,
by quite a bit."
So we'll dedicate that to
Martin Luther King, a great man.
Dr. King?
How did he get in this?
What do you mean, dedicate?
Dr. King's not
your 16-year-old girlfriend.
What does that mean?
(groans)
But let me just break down that
entire statement for you guys.
Okay, Liberty students
are required by the university
to attend these rallies.
So if Trump broke a record
for attendance,
it's only because
Liberty enrollment is up,
not because every student
actually wanted to be there.
So he's basically talking out
of his ass, which, by the way,
he wants to dedicate
to Dr. King.
-Mm. But Tru...
-(awwing)
(laughing):
Okay.
"Aw, Larry."
But Trump vowed to fight
for this religion
he so clearly
never thinks about.
We're going
to protect Christianity.
And I can say that. I don't have
to be politically correct or...
Or correct-correct.
All right, Donald. You're being
a little too general.
You need to be more specific,
Donald.
You know, quote something.
I... You know, I got an idea.
Quote something every Christian
would know--
or even non-Christians--
you know,
something
like Second Corinthians, right?
I mean, who hasn't heard
of Second Corinthians?
I hear this is a major theme
right here,
but Two Corinthians, right?
Two Corinthians 3:17.
That's the whole ball game.
"Where the spirit
of the Lord..." Right?
"Where the spirit of the Lord
is, there is liberty."
And here there is
Liberty College, but...
Liberty University,
but it is so true.
You know, when you think...
And that's really...
Is that the one?
Is that the one you like?
(groaning)
There is so much wrong
with that.
You know what I love about this?
He doesn't even know
how wrong "Two Corinthians"
sounds, right?
He's oblivious to it.
And when people laugh,
he acts like he was
the originator
of that mysterious joke.
Now,
for you non-religious people,
let me see
if I can give you an analogy.
Let's say
you're a big Star Wars fan,
and someone comes to speak
to your Star Wars group.
Um, in this scenario,
you have no life, okay?
They say they're
a huge Star Wars fan,
that they have a great
relationship with Star Wars,
okay? Mmm.
And then they say, "Okay, I want
to talk about the Farce, right?
"We're all strong
with the Farce, right?
"That's what you guys like, the
Farce. You know what I'm saying?
"I know. You're laughing.
'Cause we love the Farce.
"Who doesn't love the Farce?
Yeah, you're still laughing
"'cause the Farce is awesome.
The Farce is strong
"with Luther Vandross Skywalker,
right?
Am I right? The Farce."
(groaning)
Okay.
It's clear that Trump
doesn't know the Bible,
but there is a book
that, uh, he knows very well.
I wrote The Art of the Deal.
Who has read The Art of the Deal
in this room?
Everybody.
I think three people clapped.
Trump says, "Everybody."
I'm sorry. But I interrupted.
You were in the middle
of some (bleep).
Please continue.
Who has read The Art of the Deal
in this room?
Everybody. I always say...
I always say a deep, deep second
to the Bible.
The Bible is the best.
The Bible.
The Bible blows it away.
There's nothing like the Bi...
Please stop it. Just
stop him from talking, please.
I can't take it anymore.
Come on, God, what,
are you out of lightning bolts?
Don't you smite anymore?
He just elevated his crappy
book, The Art of the Deal,
to just below the Bible.
Can't you see what he's trying
to do, Liberty U?
He's trying to close the deal
on you guys.
He's trying to convince you
that he's just like you.
Evangelicals,
you have to listen to me.
Look, you can be forgiven for
falling in love with Ted Cruz
and Black Droopy the Dog.
Hmm? But you'll never
be forgiven
for falling in love
with this troll.
You know what?
It's probably hard for you to
hear me when I talk like this.
You know, let me say it
more evangelically, all right?
(organ music playing)
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
I'm talking to you,
evangelicals.
You know you make up 57%
of the caucus-goers,
-so you are our last hope.
-(audience shouting out)
For the bulwark
against the creep of evil ivy
-that is Donald Trump.
-(audience chatter)
And he is growing wild!
Can I get an amen?
AUDIENCE:
Amen!
He is a snake in the grass,
and you must cast him out
like the devil!
-(audience shouting out)
-"2 Corinthians"?
What man of God can't name
a bible verse?
(audience shouting out)
How about... how about...
how about, "Jesus wept?"
(whoops and shouting)
'Cause Jesus himself is weeping
at how big an asshole
Donald Trump is.
Did I say asshole?
Yes, I did.
But God will forgive me 'cause
I'm talking about Donald Trump.
I'm gonna need another "amen"
over here very quickly!
-AUDIENCE: Amen!
-All right.
And who in the name
of the Almighty
doesn't know the New Testament
from the Old?
WOMAN:
You tell 'em, Preacher.
The Old Testament is the one
with all the damn smiting.
Some of us knows
there is a difference!
-(audience shouting)
-WOMAN: There's a difference!
What I challenge you to do,
evangelicals,
is to smite down
Donald Trump's campaign!
MAN:
Hallelujah!
Smite it down!
Give me an amen
for the smiting down!
AUDIENCE:
Amen!
Smite down the Trump campaign
and loose ourselves of the grip
that this-this...
MAN:
Take your time now.
WOMAN:
Take your time! Take your time!
-(applause)
-I can't do this.
-WOMAN: Take your time.
-I will.
(overlapping shouting)
Hold on.
WOMAN:
Hallelujah! Hallelujah!
-That this... that this false
prophet. -(whooping)
This idolater has on the caucus.
He is a fever
that must be broken,
-and the only cure is truth!
-WOMAN: Truth!
-Am I right about the truth?
-(overlapping shouting)
Then how did I not get an amen
for the truth?
AUDIENCE:
Amen!
-Y'all don't hear me this
morning! -(overlapping shouting)
Now let's exorcise
this demonic abomination
from our national conversation!
Remove this devil-uh
from the... from the...
-from the voting booth-uh!
-(audience voicing assent)
Cast him-uh forth!
Cast him...
Let me hear you say
"Cast him-uh."
AUDIENCE:
Cast him-uh!
-Let me hear you say "Forth-uh!"
-AUDIENCE: Forth-uh!
-Let me hear you just say "Uh!"
-AUDIENCE: Uh!
-(laughter, overlapping shouts)
-Yeah.
Yield... yield not
to the temptation of Trump,
but be sure
to send along your donations
-to The Nightly Show ministries.
-(laughter)
No donation is too big or too
small in the eyes of the Lord.
Much like Jesus,
we'll be right back.
-(cheers and applause)
-Can I get an amen? Uh...